[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Well, it's a wrap.
On behalf of the
Next Live Show crew,
thank you for hanging out
with us the last three days.
SPEAKER 2: We had a great
time sharing the Google Cloud
Next '19 experience with you.
SPEAKER 1: But it
doesn't end here.
Everything we've livestreamed--
the keynotes, the recaps,
the Next Live Show experience,
and all the sessions at Next
will be available
to watch, share,
and rewatch on our video on
demand page at g.co/nextonair.
SPEAKER 2: Next '19 is about to
go global as it heads to Tokyo
and then London later this year.
Follow us at g.co/cloudnext
to stay in the know.
So long from San Francisco.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you
so much for watching.
SPEAKER 2: And we'll
see you next year.
[MUSIC PLAYING]